I think everyone's a liar and you're
lying if you say you're not a liar
I'm kind of worried that me being honest
is going to make people think that I'm
inadequate or I'm a mean person
maybe I lie to protect myself but also I
lie to protect other people sometimes
the truth hurts and sometimes the truth
is very dark and something that a lot of
people don't want to hear being honest
it scares me in terms of all my
relationships because I guess I lie
everybody I swore to tell the truth
whole truth and nothing but the truth
for the next 24 hours
so the lady at the Burger King
drive-thru gave me a compliment and she
was like oh I love your hair oh I want
your hair and I was like you know what
it's not mine so you can have it too
just go to the store and buy it
I had a friend text me asking if I
wanted to hang out and I told them I had
an audition caught myself and had to
write back no I actually lied I just
feel like lying in my bed doing nothing
today felt very lame
hey Steven I never told you this but
before we met I liked your dog a lot
more than you what I'm sorry I'm just
being honest
so I went to dinner and the waiter asked
us how her meal was and what did you
tell her it wasn't good if you can't say
that - wait you can't do that but it was
cold it wasn't very good so just got
back from the state um a few things he
appreciated that I was honest about a
lot of things and I think that um you
know it allowed him to open up and be a
lot more honest about himself because I
was being so blunt and I was like hey we
vibe really well as friends maybe we
should hang out next time as like
friends I didn't even know what and say
that so honesty kind of sucked today
being honest for a day made me feel like
an [ __ ] I was honest for a day and in
the end nothing really changed like the
world didn't blow up I still have my
friends I still have my family I went on
a date and I didn't like the person and
now I never have to see them again it's
great being honest didn't ruin my life
nothing changed I still have my mom and
she didn't disown me my boyfriend still
lives with me and he hasn't disowned me
yet and I still have my job so things
are going smoothly I think that was just
a relief just to kind of let go of that
side of myself that wants to be a people
pleaser and wants to put my best face
forward instead of really saying what's
on my mind maybe I should start being a
little more honest about the small stuff
and see what happens and
push myself out of my comfort zone I'm
really glad that we did this experiment
just because it's kind of put things in
perspective for me you know it's a
little bit more important for me to feel
comfortable and for me to feel happy
than to compromise all that for the
happiness of others
[Music]
you